So, you have the heart framework to
think about categories and metrics.
Now, which metrics should you actually
track to make data informed decisions?
Well, that will depend on your product.
You want to create
a small set of metrics or
key performance indicators that
everyone on your team cares about.
To do that,
here's a process that can help you.
First, you should think about
the top-level goals for
the product or feature.
This is a good time to check in
with stakeholders, investors, and
anyone else on the team.
The discussion allows you to
collect different ideas for
the goals and build consensus about
which goals are most important.
Now, a common mistake is to define
the goals in terms of the metric.
For example, you might say that your
goal is to increase the number of people
who make a purchase, which is common for
many e-commerce websites.
Instead, you should think about
the user experience improvements
that could help drive that change.
So be sure to narrow in on
your definition of the goal.
Next, you want to pair low level
signals to each of the goals.
For example, at Udacity,
an engagement signal might be,
how many minutes of video a user
watches with each session.
You might also look at failure signals,
such as failed searches when a user
searches for something, but
doesn't click on any results.
Once you have a couple signals down, you
should ask some additional questions to
determine which signals might be best.
First, you should ask how easy or
difficult is it to track this signal?
You might be able to come
up with a better proxy or
a different signal to
track that same thing.
It may be that the website or
app is not instrumented to log
relevant events and actions.
So, you might need to do some
additional research at this point.
Another question you should ask is,
is the signal sensitive to changes in
the design of the website or the app?
After you've thought
about your goals and
your signals, it's time to
craft your specific metrics.
The metrics you choose should
be prioritized based on the main
goals of the product
that you defined first.
You can always come back to refine
the metrics based on what you need do or
from what you learned.
You also want to be careful
about adding too many metrics.
Often times, your metrics will
be associative with one another.
And you want the ones that tell
you about user behavior and
about your product.
You want the metrics that
inform you of what to do next.
Download the template in the
downloadables and write your own goals,
signals, and metrics for some of
the categories in the HEART Framework.
You don't need to have a goal for
every category.
Just think about two or
three goals that you think are most
important to measure for your product.
Once you've done this activity,
check this box to continue.